>>Teacher: Yeah, yeah.
>>Gregory: This first step
is to change that self talk.
I think should go to college.
I could go to college.
I'm going to go to college.
I'm going to graduate college.
The only person that
could stop you is you.
>>Teacher: We have a hundred
percent college acceptance rate.
We believe that if you put the right
support mechanisms around our young men,
they have an opportunity to rise above
the challenges that they often deal
with and become successful.
>>Dion: Back in two thousand six
when we first started operating,
we'd hear the statistics
being about two percent
of African American males were
actually graduating from college.
The goal is to make them
want to go to college,
as well as give them a very clear
insight as to what to expect in college.
>>Desmond: Soon as you come in the door,
it's just you getting ready
for the real work, buddy.
Like it's a wake up call.
It's in the atmosphere.
Like you can't say Urban
Prep without thinking, man,
these guys are going to college.
>>Gregory: Good morning, good
morning, good morning, good morning.
>>I actually grew up two
blocks from the school.
So when I'm talking about college in
my classes, I'm constantly stressing
to them, I know exactly
your frustrations.
>>Begin to plan, begin to set up
how you will solve your problem.
If you don't change that talk, you
will continue to get the same results.
>>Lionel: People can't believe
they can be what they don't see.
So they never met a graduate
college graduate,
they don't think that
that's a possibility.
So we start to plant
those seeds very early on.
>>Tim: The first field trip they go
on when they are freshmen
is to a college campus.
We want them to understand
that in four years,
you're going to be at a place like this.
>>Donte: Every teacher has their college
pennant where they graduated from.
Students can look up and see, "Oh, can
you tell me more about this school?"
>>Christopher: And when you all apply to
DePaul University, I know you're going
to want to do early admissions, because
you've already made up your mind
and you really want to go there.
Let's figure out what it
takes to get into this school.
>>Lionel: Unfortunately, the majority of
our students enter Urban Prep unprepared
for the rigors of high school.
>>Teacher: Students were coming to us
and they were reading at
the fifth grade level.
>>Lionel: And none of them
were able to perform math
above the seventh grade level.
So we've had to design an academic
model that allows us to remediate
and accelerate almost simultaneously.
It's a double period of
English for four years.
>>Teacher: So let's go ahead and start
off with one of our strong opinions.
Who's ready to go?
>>Student: She inherited that name,
she wanted to escape that name,
which means she wanted to also
escape the Mexican heritage.
>>Student: I strongly disagree,
because I can change my last name,
but that may be because I want to escape
my American culture that's been forced
onto me.
>>Lionel: They take a double period
of math freshman and sophomore year,
where we really want to build that
foundation at algebra and geometry.
What the research supports is
that if students are algebra ready
by the time they complete
their freshman year,
they are more likely
to succeed in college.
>>Success in college is dependent
upon the student's academic ability,
but also their social
and emotional skills.
>>Christopher: What are some
of the issues that you feel men
of color might face in
their first year of college?
>>Student: Racism, of course,
because if you look on the news,
there's a lot of fraternities.
>>Christopher: Are you talking about
some of the black face incidents?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Christopher: Yeah.
Can you get up and go
punch somebody in the face
because they're making
fun of your culture?
>>Students: No.
>>Christopher: No, but how do you
advocate for yourself and educate them
to know like, yo, that's not cool?
>>Lionel: Once they become seniors,
we have a college process class.
>>Student: Actually type it up.
>>DaShawn: Before Urban
Prep, college was more of,
if I go, I go, if I don't, I don't.
But once getting here, college
is a must, like I have to go.
Recently I have been having
to look up colleges to find
out information about them.
We fill out certain applications.
We work on our personal statement.
>>Student: I said I am
a very quick learner.
This skill will be very useful in
college because I have aspirations
to become a teacher and it takes
a lot of patience and learning
to be successful in a
teaching environment.
>>Donte: We talk to them about,
you know, what to include
in your essay, what not to include.
We talk about financial aid.
>>Jessica: They're encouraged to apply
to eleven schools, two probable schools,
a reach school, two safety schools.
We want them to have
a variety of options.
>>DaShawn: I was like, I don't
believe I can get into these schools,
but she was just like, "You most
definitely have the scores."
She pushed me to sit there and say,
"I'm not going to let a school deny me."
>>Student: It teaches
us about responsibility.
It's our job to get the essays done and
finish all our applications on our own
and then have them check off on it.
>>DaShawn: I think about
college every day.
I'm so amped up for it right now,
it's just a burden burning
in me to get there.
>>Lionel: The best ritual in the world
to me is what we call
"On to the Next One."
It's when we present our seniors
with their red and gold tie
for being accepted to their
first college or university.
>>Ke'Avery: I had trouble sleeping
last night because of the excitement.
>>Darius: I've been accepted
into Anthem University,
Tuskegee University,
St. John's University.
>>Jeramee: I feel good.
I've been waiting four long
years for this red and gold tie.
>>Lionel: This is a generational
shift, so now all of his cousins
and siblings are looking
to him and saying, "Hey,
if he did it, then I can do it too."
>>Tim: We're changing this
narrative around what is possible
for young black men, what is possible
for this possible for this population,
what is possible for these communities.